ils sont cinq à s'être officiellement
déclaré candidat aux nouvelles élections
municipales organisées à trappes parmi
eux le maire dont la victoire a été
invalidée en août dernier à lire ab les
aussi son principal opposant othman
nassr où ce dernier s'était incliné avec
sa liste avec moins de 3 % d'écart en
2020 dès que les trappistes ouvrons la
tête à l'élection municipale ou début
septembre j'irai vers eux pour
m'exprimer leur expliquer la situation
faire le bilan aussi d'un nombre
travailler au service des trappistes il
faut avoir cela en tête en moins d'un an
nous avons réussi à la fois à rétablir
le soutien scolaire à mettre en place la
semaine des quatre jours à baisser le
prix de la cantine par exemple pour les
enfants notamment les plus modestes et
pour les classes moyennes je défends un
projet encore une fois sur l'emploi sur
la jeunesse sur la sécurité sur les
questions de santé et sur la bonne
gestion
et on voit que c'est un vrai sujet la
bonne gestion je défends ce projet
depuis des années maintenant sur la
qualité du logement donc je vais me
battre pour que ce projet là soit
adoptée par une majorité des trappistes
qui iront effectivement se mobiliser
parce que le vrai sujet que nous avons
c'est un sujet de mobilisation des
électeurs
contacté par notre rédaction guy
malandain ancien maire de trappes de
2001 à 2020 présent au second tour des
dernières élections n'a pas encore
indiqué son choix la question d'un
rapprochement avec othman nasri serait
envisagé trois autres listes ont elles
d'ores et déjà annoncé leur
participation
portées par luc miserait la liste trappe
à gauche défend un projet décliné autour
de douze priorités santé logement
travail ou encore éducation sont
présents la question de l'accompagnement
des personnes et pas simplement de
celles qui sont en difficulté mais
particulièrement de celles qui sont en
difficulté se présente de manière
accrue par par l'ensemble des crise que
l'on traverse et qui n'épargne pas notre
ville problème d'éducation
il nous semble qu'il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui est proposé aussi
bien d'un point de vue qualitatif que
dans la diversité des propositions pour
représenter l'extrême gauche une liste
menée par patrick plan qu il veut faire
valoir la lutte ouvrière cruellement le
camp des travailleurs n'est pas
représentée dans ces élections et
aujourd'hui faire entendre ce camp des
gens qui sont opprimés qui sont
exploités et qui font tourner dans la
société bien évidemment c'est
indispensable c'est très intéressant de
discuter aujourd'hui parce que on
rencontre une force sympathie pour cette
cette idée qui va falloir se défendre et
organiser tous ensemble contre les
mauvais coups du patronat et du
gouvernement pour finir une candidature
à deux visages présents aux élections
départementales robert naga retina mais
son frère ronsard portent ensemble la
liste ensemble pour l'environnement et
l'économie solidaire parmi leurs idées
la protection des parcs et l'abaissement
du prix du ticket de bus à 1 euro tout
simplement parce que nous sommes proches
proche de la population on écoute on
vivait que tous les jours et en plus
nous sommes depuis longtemps l'habitude
attrape presque 45 ans ont vécu à
trappes ont étudié à trappes non écoute
à tous la population on l'écouté qu'est
ce qu'on va faire a continué à faire
partir par qu'on continue notre marche
et en contenus expliqué à nos idées
comme combat commun mentionné par tous
les candidats la lutte contre
l'absentéisme des électeurs de trappes
invités aux urnes les 10 et 17 octobre
prochains lors du second tour des
municipales en 2020 seuls 34% des
électeurs s'étaient rendus aux urnes